there's a lot of different types of
nightclubs the clubs that i studied are
they offer what's called bottle service
where instead of waiting at the bar to
get your drink
you can pay a pretty high price you know
starting 500
on up to 5000 or more to sit at a table
and basically rent the table for the
night and then bottles of alcohol get
brought to your table and then
people use this as an opportunity to
show off how much money they can spend
on champagne because the
big expensive bottles come out with
sparklers or they you know are
brought to the table by very attractive
uh young women that are called bottle
girls so it's a clear case of
conspicuous consumption
it affords an opportunity to show off in
this kind of club world
i'm joined by ashley mears ashley
welcome to the show
hi good to be here great to have you
here
tell me your background tell everyone
that's listening what your the 30 000
foot view of
who you are okay
um so i'm a sociologist
i i teach in i teach courses in pop
culture
and economic sociology and gender um
and my research kind of broadly
is in what we could call cultural
economics
but um basically the cultural
foundations of
um value um and how that plays out in
different markets and i've
focused on pretty atypical cases for
social scientists and that is um the
fashion modeling industry which was my
dissertation and became a book later
called pricing beauty
and then my most recent book is about um
high-end nightclubs and the uh the
fact of champagne waste so
i know i describe it in fairly bland
terms somewhat deliberately because as
an academic
you know there's an impetus to kind of
be serious and
present your stuff and kind of
theoretically and conceptually
recognizable terms uh but yeah i study
in this kind of fun
worlds i listened
to your episode compass on conversations
with tyler
yeah um talking about this stuff
and hearing two academic you you
remained mostly academic
but he is pure like he was asking a
question of like why is the music so
why does the music have to be so loud in
nightclubs which is just like
just the most pure academic question and
it's like
actually that's fairly good so i want to
i want to try and take a
an academics perspective a sociological
anthropological perspective of
nightclubs and
nightlife how do you how would you lay
it out imagine i'm
another academic i've never been in a
nightclub i don't know why people go
i don't know what the purpose is give it
give us the full monty
well that that would make you like a lot
of academics actually
so um so yeah well first there's
there's a lot of different types of
nightclubs there's clubs out there that
cater to pretty much any kind of
you know niche and attraction and like
kink or whatever but
the clubs that i studied are um they
offer what's called bottle service
where instead of waiting at the bar to
get your drink you can
um pay a pretty high price you know
starting 500
on up to 5 000 or more to sit at a table
and basically rent the table for the
night and then bottles of alcohol get
brought to your table and then
people use this as an opportunity to
show off how much money they can spend
on champagne because the
big expensive bottles come out with
sparklers or they
you know are brought to the table by
very attractive
young women that are called bottle girls
um so it's a clear case of conspicuous
consumption
it affords an opportunity to show off in
this kind of club world
but if you're just you know wanting to
hit the like
i don't know the 80s dance party you
know that
that is used to be up the street from my
house you know
what people seek out in in all kinds of
nightlife experiences is the
the opportunity to um kind of lose
oneself
in the moment in the music and this
explains why the music is so loud
because
it you know you you're no longer
distracted as much by the fact of other
other people um and that kind of
co-presence and
like mutual focus on something like you
know loud music or
if everybody knows the words to a song
right i mean this
this is a pretty this can be a really
magical experience that clubs offer it's
um collective effervescence is that
right that's right
yeah yeah so there's a you know old
theoretical term for it by the
french theorist daniel durkheim that um
refers to this as collective
effervescence
the kind of losing yourself in the
moment with other people it's kind of
the defining logic of
nightclubs of burning man you can feel
it it protests you can feel it at the
you know football game when people are
chanting together
it's that excitement of of being with
other people
okay that's why the music's so loud
that's right
that's why the music's so loud why are
people spending money
getting bottles to their table yeah so
um there's a lot of different
explanations for this the one that
that i focused on um is looking at the
extreme
sums of money that people were paying
which really was kind of
bizarre and you know struck this
curiosity in me that
um so i started this project it was
around 2011
and um you know bottle service was at
its peak and
i was reading reports of people that
were spending you know thousands of
dollars
um oligarchs you know outbidding each
other saying who could spend more
on champagne that they wouldn't even
drink maybe they would just gift the
bottles to people
in the room and you know 2011 is a
moment where there's a kind of global
financial austerity because the world is
still reeling from
the financial meltdown of 2008. and so i
just thought that you know the
disjuncture
there was just so fascinating that i
wanted to understand
um how people could engage in in that
kind of ostentatious behavior
so the the explanations that i put
forward are really anthropological that
um you know on the on the one hand this
is fairly
this is kind of a timeless behavior the
um
showing off of status through the
through waste
um and there's a term that
anthropologists use for this
that um was documented in studies of
tribal societies in the pacific
northwest where um
tribal nobility would gather together
you know the tribe and
and uh compete with one another to see
who could give away
the most you know valuable things who
could hold the biggest feast who could
waste the most food
um that's called a polish that would
have real consequences for somebody's
claim to status and prestige and that
you know they could solidify rank
in that way so it was really
consequential uh nightclubs are not that
consequential this kind of you know
popping bottles in a nightclub
um but it is it is you know one of many
forms that we see throughout history of
people asserting their status through
waste
through the display of waste um and so
that's one explanation
that i find quite fascinating and then
it you know there's a bunch of other
um plausible explanations some people go
to clubs and spend in these sums of
money
because they want to be in the milieu of
people like themselves
which could lead to business
opportunities so especially for people
who work in finance this might be an
opportunity to meet or to
or to entertain clients which could be
written off as a business expense
um you know so there's peacocking
there's the kind of practical
um connectivity in a business world
um and yeah i think that for some people
this this kind of uh participation in
this world
really is um kind of the pinnacle
of of achieving something that is quite
meaningful in pop culture broadly
right because you get to be in these
glamorous settings surrounded by fashion
models
um where your behavior is essentially
immortalized in hip-hop lyrics that are
celebrated around the world
and you get to perform that and so
that's what clubs are offering
i i i get it why why are the girls on
the tables why are they there
yeah yeah yeah um so the
the girls that um that i that i studied
uh in this circuit they they tend to be
young women who are um very beautiful in
the way that the fashion
modeling industry defines beauty of
typically very young
very thin predominantly but not
exclusively white
with a kind of rarified beauty that
people would recognize as
a fashion model and so that kind of
beauty communicates status
because it's rare because it's been
legitimated by the fashion modeling
industry even if the men who are
spending money might not be attracted to
that kind of body
those are the kinds of women um who are
are kind of displayed
in the room as a means of communicating
and elevating the status
of not just the room and the place but
all of the people
in that space as well so that's a
certain kind of entourage so this kind
of spending wouldn't be possible without
that kind of entourage
why it would be considered meaningless
it would be
um nobody nobody would kind of see
the the expense of the bottle as being
um
as being worth it if the crowd were not
deemed high status enough
as worthy to impress which fashion
models are
right okay um and
most of the guys are on these tables
they're not planning on dating the girls
really they're not sort of long-term
uh prospects despite the fact that
they're quite beautiful why do you think
that is
um yeah so that's my that is something
that's a bit of a
puzzle that i found but it kind of
depends what you mean by dating because
that has a different time horizon for
different people
uh long long term prospects should i say
long-term
relationship marriage right family uh
yeah well it's definitely the case so
there are a lot of
hookups that happen and probably
short-term relationships that form out
of nightclubs
some of them in the nightclubs some of
them in the nightclubs that's right
yeah um but among the among the people
that are
um that have money that have
professional careers
that are kind of showing off in these
spaces
um that pool of upper class men uh tends
to
partner with a similar pool of
upper-class women
um there's a certain homophily you know
like
um birds of a feather flock together
kind of logic where if you look at
uh marriage patterns people tend to
partner with people like themselves in
terms of their education credentials or
their family background or their
occupational prestige and earnings
and the perception among the clients who
are the bottle buyers
in these spaces is that models are great
company to have for the night
uh but not for the long term that they
actually was quite surprising
how i mean the value that models
generate to the nightclub industry
it's almost like they're priceless right
they communicate status
people will spend more money with models
in the room promoters can make their
careers off of models
they're creating so much profit and yet
as people
um models are really seen as worthless
they're seen as like air-headed
not serious right a woman that goes out
frequently in these spaces
doesn't buy her own drinks can't afford
maybe to buy her own drinks must be some
kind of failure in life
not the kind of woman you would take
home to meet mom okay
um where are the affluent
young high status women
this is a really good question do you
know no do you know who they are no
no actually but if you could get me
their phone numbers
uh in an excel spreadsheet and send them
over to me
uh as an aspiring trophy husband that
would be
wonderful so i want to do a project on
um i mean you call it trophy husband you
know trophy wives is it
all these are variations of economically
asymmetrical
relationships i'm really fascinated
where um
you have such imbalances of power i mean
the trophy
unions um sugar baby sugar daddies
groupies there's all kinds of different
versions of this and i think that those
relationships could really
reveal important lessons for everybody
else about um
how how people how people manage
power inequalities in their
relationships um
but flipping that power dynamic on its
head is an interesting one
yeah very very interesting so where are
they where are the where's the where's
the
25 year old with a 25 year old female
with a seven-figure net worth was she
um well because of the way that
um gender tends to operate in
professional realms
um there is there is still a pretty big
uh wage gap
in the professions and actually across
the labor market
um there's you know those kinds of
fields in which you see people who are
very young turning out lots of money
they tend to be male dominated fields
you know so like in tech for instance um
or some sectors of finance
so yeah 25 is a little bit young for
anybody but i think especially for women
to have
i think the the the young enough to
still party in
phd or lavo brunch or whatever it might
be
yeah so it wouldn't be the phd set but
maybe you you could try your luck with
like the influencers
i meant phd the nightclub in new york
not phd
sorry so this is where they should
rebrand
yeah that's right um but no actually
just thinking about where the areas are
in which women
do really well at young ages i mean
i am thinking about like the instagram
influencers those are
where you see um kind of really powerful
like up and coming business people
but business women i think kind of
starting their companies and building
brands why they're not
why they're not buying a bottle big big
table getting guys
making them making them go and eat like
the second-rate sushi downstairs before
they come up why is that not happening
they should yeah so um
so it's a realm in which
it's kind of built on the assumption of
men
as consumers and it's built on the
assumption of heterosexual
uh male taste and the male gaze and so
you know
women are kind of brought in as the
decor um
and it's the assumption that men are the
spenders it's not that there's never any
women spenders there certainly are
but they're pretty rare and they're
talked about it's like did you see that
that was weird right what's a female
whale
uh there's a cup yeah like a couple of
um a whalers i guess they would just be
called whales
but that's you know to be called away
with a guy in a nightclub is a
a badge of honor to be called a whale in
the nightclub is this little worse
that's right yeah there's it's not so
flattering right yeah yeah
um so for women in the clubs like for
women to get into the club the most
important thing that they have is not
not money but beauty and so there are
you know lots of instances where women
who were
working in high powered positions in
finance for instance would want to go
out
afterward after work with their team to
one of these places and
might get rejected at the door or might
end up in some really awkward
negotiation she can't come in because
she's only five foot five
right and like i mean how humiliating
right and so
um so this yeah i mean perhaps if
a woman had you know so much money or so
much celebrity i mean that could
that could trump um the body size but
but really
um to get in women have to have this
what we might call bodily capital
whereas men
can have money to get in they could have
connections they could have celebrity
um and as in the end as long as they're
good looking and friendly they could
still get in as filler to like buy their
drinks at the bar
um but you know but some
some women could actually get denied
entry and could get
really insulted like to her face so it's
not just a night entry it's like
denied entry cruelly yeah well i mean
many men
will be denied entry at the door if you
turn up as a group of guys
and you're not spending a huge amount of
money if you turn up without
girls you're not that's right that's
right yeah yeah yeah
so there's there's limits um for the men
as well just based on
this gender so there's a there's an
amount of capital that you need
and that capital appears to be selecting
asymmetrically between men and women and
there are certain pathways
that are completely being deselected for
and that is determined highly by the
sort of environment that you're going to
go in
someone's academic uh
accomplishments their um
ability to uh elucidate their ideas
uh how articulate they are um their
ability to be a good cook
unless that's been monetized um because
you have
loud music drunk people very visceral
um sort of skin deep by by like by
definition
um experience going on none of those
qualities are given chance to manifest
therefore they're not valued at the door
that's right
yeah yeah yeah the music is loud and you
know the lights are low and so it
what really matters is not your sterling
personality um
unless of course it has been monetized
in some kind of celebrity
but you know there's i don't know i i do
think that your point about selection is
is accurate that you know these kinds of
places attract people that probably
are already um are already on the side
of like
getting in right and and some people um
who maybe know about these places would
know that they wouldn't be welcome
and that in itself would be reason not
to even try
no one wants to be turned away at the
door right like it's the it's a
the thing of social nightmares um that
being said bergain
which you may be familiar with in
germany the techno club um is
famous for having a doorman who turns
people away for no reason
and that's got nothing to do with how
much money you have that's like
have you seen there's an app available
which
teaches you how to get into burgain
i read about it yeah i didn't see it
because i'm one of those people that
would never try
oh yeah i'm too horrified at the
possibility that i could wait in line
for an hour
and then not get in you know drive drive
in the middle of nowhere go to somewhere
that looks like
something out 28 days later and then
yeah wait in the freezer i've never been
i've got a couple of buddies i've been
got a few buddies that have been
if you're listening and you've been to
burger king tell us whether you got in
how you got in if you know anyone that
got knocked back by that
that crazy scary guy on the door that's
got like 45 piercings and face tattoos
and stuff like
that but yeah it's like you have to go
in groups of three
two people must be wearing black it's
advisable to have something on you
that's
leather like you know all of this and
you should always know the
who the djs are yeah yeah yeah exactly
um
just claim that solomon's djing that's
like that's the best thing to do just
signal with the fact that you think it's
probably solomon
and then it's like is it not solomon i
swear it was i bet he was supposed to be
oh this guy knows what he's on about
that's right that's right
a bloody doo i went to uni with the
jamie jones's
younger sister jenny jones actually
who's a
cool girl um okay so you've you've just
redictated to me an industry i've worked
in for a decade and a half
like i've run nightclubs for 14 years
i've
watched more drunk people than i can
remember stumble in and out
um and yeah it only it took me until a
couple of years ago to realize
what the experience was selecting for
like
why at its very very core people were
going
and that collective effervescence it
really seems to be one of the driving
factors of that
it's a place where other people
like you are so it's selecting
already for a particular social group
which is like where you get um the uk
type of promotion that we do is less
bottle service
and um tables it's lower value
higher volume so we'll do two thousand
one thousand to two thousand to two and
a half thousand kids a night
four nights a week but it'll be just buy
drinks at the bar
tables are just free basically for
birthdays um and we try and do high
volume
um but again with that that's even more
so about that community side
right so it's the same people will go
it's the same night
every week with the same drink stills
the same sort of djs sometimes we even
play the same songs at the same time
um so they know the rhythm is
predictable yeah
that's cool yeah it's interesting but um
what else what else did you learn tell
us about the tell us about the party
girls
and about what what your learnings were
spending a bit of time with them because
you went
you got in the trenches for this this
wasn't an armchair
philosophy job this was you you weren't
in the trenches donned your high heels
and cracked on right
that's right yeah and some of my some of
my colleagues in
academia they would kind of joke about
it like oh ashley
you know such hard field work you have
you know in miami at these nightclubs
you know with all this champagne i was
like it was awful
there were some moments particularly in
miami because i was following this
promoter who was like a real party
animal i mean he would chase the after
parties until like eight
ten o'clock in the morning and uh i
remember yeah at one point i was like
there's some you know beautiful space
surrounded by beautiful people
and all of this you know symbols of
money coming out
and i like went into the bathroom and
just cried
i couldn't take you know i was like i'm
in the dredges of humanity
wiped my tears came back out it's like
partying again
[Laughter]
but i may have been really sleep
deprived at that moment too um
yeah so the the
field work is um it's called immersive
ethnography this kind of you know
sometimes we call it participant
observation but i kind of flip it it's
more like observant participation so i
really did become
a girl this was my point of access you
know i could have done the study
in any other kind of way just by
interviews
or um you know if if i didn't look the
way i did
and was a woman i probably would have
had a harder time getting access
um but because of the the access that i
had
um so i'm i'm was an x model
uh and i was doing this field work and i
was about 32
which is much older than most of the
other young women that are called girls
but girl
is not just referring to their youth
it's also a kind of social category it
marks a woman as like that type of
woman that belongs in the space is a
girl
um and so the the way that i got in was
is um
i'm a girl that would be known as a good
civilian
uh which so civilian is is a kind of
term
from the military which refers to
somebody who's not really part of the
action right
um and then a good civilian is somebody
who's like
maybe not exactly a working model but
good enough right like
when the lights are low she's like she's
she's acceptable if she puts
if she should have danced dances with
her back to us for long enough like
if i can work my heels then you know
she's got the height
um i know you know and i had the same
body measurements
um so yeah i got in as a good civilian
and i followed the promoters
um and i would follow them uh from the
start of the night which is
you know kind of unfathomably late at
this point in my life but it would be
dinner at ten o'clock
and then into a nightclub at midnight
and then staying into a nightclub
into like three or four o'clock in the
morning and sometimes i would really
push it and try to stay as late as the
promoters which meant going to after
parties
um or staying you know past closing and
yeah this was uh this was pretty intense
field work even at that
age um you know i think for for me by 32
i had kind of
i was kind of over this this kind of
forms of sociality you know i was i was
a little bit um
i always think if i had met promoters
when i was like 18 i probably would have
had a much different
experience with them what a dream yeah
yeah yeah because i
you know i liked clubbing and i really
liked all forms of dance music and
and free things yeah i like free
champagne
i don't know i don't know who doesn't
like free things
that's right although you know that's
also one of the kind of ideas of the
book is that there's really
no such thing as a free lunch that um
the
the gift always has a counter gift or it
anytime you give a gift there's this
expectation of reciprocity and that's in
the anthropology of marcel mose who
argued that arguably
at the root of any society is the gift
it's exchange
because if i give you something i've put
you in a relationship with me and you
have to reciprocate in some way and so i
forged a tie and so these ties are kind
of the building blocks of community
and in the nightclub world the gifts
do flow like for good reason like
there's all kinds of
free drinks free dinners the promoters
are
spending so much time during the day uh
giving favors to models taking them to
lunch driving them to their castings
taking them bowling
you know like you know hanging out with
them flirting with them making them feel
special
uh building a relationship with them so
that then the girls will
reciprocate and and people do really
talk about promoters as their friends
even though they know that promoters are
making money off of them and i don't
think that the girls are fooled it's not
like a you know old school marxist story
of like false consciousness
it is a story about like the power of
the gift that like this is
this is a kind of relational um
relational economy it's like piece
together through relationships and
there's work that goes into making those
relationships and making them feel
good and not exploitative which
objectively it is
[Music]
why do the girls not want to just get
paid why don't they say just give me
give me money
yeah so some of them do but it's pretty
rare um so when money exchanges hands
usually it's earmarked so it'll be like
i'll come out with you but you're gonna
pay my cabs right like you pay my cab
fare 40 bucks
um so that's a case of like it's not
just cash it's like cash for a purpose
um and then some of the promoters will
offer um
housing in what's known as like a model
house or model apartment
and so the girls will get to live that's
supplied by
a promoter yes so select or models one
or [ __ ] storm aren't putting girls up
in new york city to do the day job
but the promoter that they eat cheap
sushi with and go
for no no so there's
there's lots of different types of
models um right storm
uh or select they'll have a legitimate
model apartment
somewhere but the promoters also know
where it is and the promoters are
calling it
trying to get them
so there's those promoters this is like
those promoters know where those model
houses are
but some promoters know that there's a
lot of girls that don't have
representation yet
and are maybe really good civilians but
they're not good enough to get in with
a legit agency yet and so they're coming
to new york
you know through their friend networks
and the promoters know their friends and
then the promoters know that they need
housing
so they'll offer them free housing in
exchange for going out say four nights a
week
yeah if you're a girl who's listening
does this sound like
absolutely heaven or absolute hell and
if you would be so kind as to just
tell me your age when you give me this
back because
i'm fascinated at why 18 year old you
would have loved it
and 32 year old you hated it what's when
did it stop and try if you can
to detract the fact that you now have a
family and
like what is it about us where you cross
is it 30 and you just like you can't
stay up after 12 o'clock without dying
the next day
yeah that's that you're so that's right
yeah um
i mean i had a career by the time i was
28 i mean
i mean i was in grad school in my 20s
and then
i started my professor job and was
really focused on trying to get tenure
and so um i think that once you once you
have a reason to wake up early in the
morning staying up late becomes harder
and harder
right if you're if you're a bit more
free and you don't have those kinds of
constraints on your time
then you you probably you know it just
feels
a lot more appropriate to be up until
the sunrise i think
so it's partly that i mean it's a life
course story i think um
it's you know it's also the fact of
doing this as research
meant that i was i was going out sober
and so i would hold a drink
and maybe take a couple sips of a drink
over the course of the night and maybe
at the end of the night take a drink
but while i was there you know everybody
else would be
drunk or high and kind of feeling it and
it's not that much fun
the sober person that's right when
you're in work mode that's when you're
ready to go cry in the bathroom
this is awful um
[Laughter]
so the question that you had asked was
why don't the why don't the girls
monetize their value what
what keeps them from doing that um
you've said that they're essentially the
they are not the currency
but they have moved themselves they have
somehow managed to move themselves
uh vertically integrate themselves
backward up the value chain to be the
thing which
drives the revenue for both
venue indirectly through encouraging
people to buy bottles to get the girls
to their tables
and directly for the promoter um because
i'm going to guess that he must be paid
based on how many girls he brings in
or and then potentially a percentage of
tables as well
that's right yeah promoters will say
that they're paid on the quantity
of quality that they bring quality
meaning how many real fashion models and
then quantity
of those um yeah is that like
so you brought in five girls that were a
six out of ten
you brought in six girls that were an
eight out of ten and one girl
what are they doing how does that work
yeah yeah so
um when they come in through the front
door you know the bouncer
will do the first screening to say like
your sixes aren't good enough
they come out right
the sixes are no good here buddy they
might
might not use that term those terms
exactly but they would you know they'll
make the first
distinction um and then at the
table uh the manager will cruise by and
make sure that
you know the enough good-looking girls
are there at the table
and and also we'll look at like with the
vibe to see if they're fun if they're
having if it's good energy if people are
dancing or people look bored
and if it's not adding the kind of
energy that they're hoping um
that they will and so so yeah there's
multiple
um i don't know gatekeepers on that
process
um but yeah the uh yeah i i propose it
to a couple of my
friends that i i know that you know were
fashion models or were still
fashion modeling at the time and was
like why don't we
just cut out these promoters and we can
go to the club
directly we just organize ourselves you
know arbitrage the market
and get paid each like 100 a night and
then
rather than the promoter getting paid
800. they were like no
that sounds like too much work and
they're not if they go out they don't
want to go out for work they're going
out really for
leisure and it's that split that people
have
you know where like if you if you pay
somebody then you move into a different
category that redefines your experience
not as fun or as leisure or something of
your own volition but as work
you know which which means that that
collective effort essence gets felt in a
really different way
um i also found that among the girls
actually among everybody that i spoke to
there was an assumption that if you were
getting
paid as a woman to be in the space you
were much closer to
this very stigmatized category of women
which is the prostitute or the sex
worker
in which there are lots of sex workers
in these spaces but it's assumed that
like the bottle girl is also for sale
so people would talk about bottle girls
as being close to sex workers
and people would talk about um fashion
models who were getting paid to be at
the tables as being kind of these
you know sad paid women that um that had
this kind of
sad fate of having to actually get paid
that's a sad paid woman
but the one that did it for some sashimi
and a couple of glasses of moe
she's somehow fine so it's not even moe
sometimes it's just like prosecco
it's just sparkling wine and uh it's not
the sashimi it's like the cucumbers
it's like the cucumber roll when you go
to these dinners you get the kind of
leftovers from the kitchen
stop bringing bellaire to your table and
claiming that it's champagne
it's not it's not it's it's prosecco
with a light eop logo that's right but
if you're 18
it's all good right so we have something
that we refer to
as bubbly which is the most
non-descript term that we could come up
with for classing what is
five percent volume sparkling perry and
this is given away for free if it's your
birthday so if it's your birthday you
get them for free uh your friends
getting on guest list you get a free
table and you get a bottle of
this bubbly but you're right like
it was just me my business partner came
up with it like 14 years ago
i swear to god there was a point at
which he had a direct contact with the
vintas that made it
because we were going through half a
pallet a week it's like it's your
birthday and it's your birthday and it's
your birthday
um why why champagne why that as a drink
yeah yeah so champagne is a high status
good you know has been for a long time
um it's it's also
like a great party beverage and because
it's like it's light and bubbly it has
that kind of
you know nice uplift in your mouth it's
like sparkly it's
also um it lends itself well to
shaking and spraying so if you want to
go nuts and make a big show of how you
can waste this rare high status good
then you can shake it and spray it
yeah and without full that's right and
you know
imagine you can't do it with like a
lambrusco right like you can't shake and
spray red because it's just
everyone so we weren't allowed my one
experience
of proper new york parking was last year
on my friend's stag do
and we went to lavo brunch on the
saturday
and the table bill came to 34 000 before
we even got to phd
then we went to phd shout out to troy
gordon who i'm going to send this to who
i'm
absolutely certain at some point soon is
going to have
a coffee table book of all of the
nightlife texts that he gets
which are something else um anyway so we
went to phd
and we'd got we'd stolen someone's
literally hijacked someone's hummus
stretch home of limousine um was firing
champagne through the roof
of this thing it's like to me
it feels an awful lot like becoming a
customer when you were originally the
supplier
uh it's like getting high on your own
supply of
industry but i was like ah i'm in
america [ __ ] it um
do what i want new york um and then
arrived at phd and we were like
just larry i don't know whether you guys
use that term in america but kind of uh
raucous and and and and loud and just
being like it's a stag dude right it's a
bachelor party yeah
and um sure enough phd is packed
um the stag starts doing handstand walks
up and down the table
like that overlooks the whole so he's
upside down doing handstand walks and
then starts spraying a bottle and we've
got it on video
and um the mc comes on on the mic
and says we don't do that here boys this
is new york city
if you do that again my friend lebron's
gonna knock you the [ __ ] out
points to lebron who is like a six foot
nine huge behemoth of a doorman
and we were like lebron's gonna come
over again sure enough
so yeah it was um that was my that was
my one experience but it's
clubbing in in america especially that
side
that like brunch stk
sort of party vibe is um something i'm
seeing increasingly moving over to
places like ibiza
so i was in ibiza last weekend socially
distanced
and in
defense of the party industry generally
that product to me feels more wholesome
than the previous incarnation which was
the ravier
um open from 10 or 11 o'clock until
6 7 in the morning with a long lineup of
djs sort of events which were
dominating the european clubbing scene
and i feel like health and wellness goes
uk us
but clubbing goes europe u.s it goes
like they we kind of swap
you're always ahead of us in terms of
wellness but we're always ahead of you
in terms of partying
that's right americans make terrible
music like sorry to everyone who's
listening
like you make good rap you get make good
rap and hip-hop but like everything else
is just awful
um so yeah i i think that's the way it
is i think that increasingly
we're seeing these sorts of parties that
are um
actually very heavily focused on
food on um the quirkiness of the
experience the bottle shows the guy in
the light up
doll outfit that comes out and dances
next to your table for no reason
the quote boards that you can hold up
that say something funny that you can
put on your instagram
and everyone from candypants events who
will be listening to this as well
including nick that runs
out in dubai and they've got some stuff
in vegas and all the rest of it
they are the um the gatekeepers of sort
of what's happening
at the moment i think with like cool
young parties like this and they have
something really really similar to what
you were talking about but i think is
i'm gonna try and put drop nick in it
too much it's more wholesome
um they have a deal with all of the
emirates girls
and all of the i think it's like the air
qatar girls so all of these
hostesses that work for them they all
drink for free eat for free entry for
free
and that's a slightly less sort of
surreptitious way of doing because it's
like
category wide right it's like if you're
it's not that you need to know the
promoter and have had sex with him and
like yeah sure sure although there is
certainly a rigorous screening of
um the emirates host election flight
attendants
right yeah yeah often from economically
disadvantaged countries like in the
balkans for instance and so there's
certainly still some inequities you know
unfortunately it is
it is a capitalist system even with i
mean i agree that these are very
beautiful and wonderful experiences and
um and a really important part of the
economy
you know and it's called the experience
economy everything from like the you
know
festivals to these kinds of
instagram-worthy kind of pop-up things
but
um but so often
what i find what makes these spaces
valuable
is the implied um
exclusivity of them which means that not
everybody can get in
right it means that inherently there's
going it's predicated on a hierarchy in
which
not everybody looks good enough to be in
your picture and can't come in
[Music]
it's interesting that for the most part
nightlife and i'll break the fourth wall
for everyone that doesn't know it
nightlife is entirely constructed
in the heads of the people who attend
and the people who don't
like if you look at lavo
brunch club or phd or stk or whatever in
the cold light of day when there's no
music on and the cleaning lights are up
and it it stinks
it's it's an awful lot smaller than you
think it is it's about
one-third the size of the venue that you
think it is when you
you're ten drinks deep and and dancing
away
um and the exclusivity all of this stuff
it's entirely socially constructed it
must be fascinating for you to look at
for you to research yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally i think
that's a really good observation
about like in the daytime you know
compared to the night time and actually
because like listening to your story
about the thirty thousand dollar bill
and you know this kind of wild night in
which you ultimately get kicked out
yeah or the threat of getting kicked out
it becomes kind of immortalized as a
story that you can tell of like i did
this
and i know that it was reckless i know
that it was silly but in the moment it
really made sense and it probably felt
really good and i found this
uh throughout the research process i
would observe people in
you know spending this kind of money
burning money shooting
champagne bottles and then in interviews
they'd be like oh yeah
you know i'm not really like that that's
very vulgar behavior i don't spend as
much as these other guys spend
and so like what people say versus what
people do or how people think and how
they construct themselves
that's a real problem in social science
because the experience self-esteem
remembered itself is just that's right
so my my master's dissertation was on
the effectiveness of
anti-alcohol advertising on students at
newcastle university
and in essence the result of the
dissertation was nothing works
like the drinking to young peoples
especially in the uk is seen as a badge
of honor
not only is it a badge of honor it's a
rite of passage there's very few things
that you can do where the
seriousness of the destruction is
directly correlated to the worthiness of
the story
like you don't say hey man how was your
football game and you said oh it was
amazing i broke my leg
you're like but if i say to you hey
ashley how was how was your night on
saturday oh my god it was so good
i got taken home in an ambulance like i
woke up i had no idea where i was
like i was missing i was missing my
shoes like i don't even know where my
shoes were
like my eyeball was on the the bedside
table next to me you know i mean like
that
they said too much but yeah but that's
the language that people
use right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've
seen that before in some stuff on like
research on alcohol and young people the
the the the badge of honor
points um is uh yeah
i mean that's a real problem also on
college campuses because
you know um here at our university as
well that's a kind of
it's a it's part of what it what is the
experience of higher education i mean
the university is also part of this
experience economy
like why else would somebody shell out
you know 50k or 70k
for university if not to have those
kinds of magical moments of like coming
of
age in this environment of you know of
the university and the dorm in the city
um and and yeah that poses a real
problem
for um for health and well-being because
alcohol is such a close
you know it's like this lubricant that
that is kind of foundational to like the
this college experience it's an
all-cause mortality risk but
when under the age of 25 you're made of
rubber and magic
so like
pretty much anything i'm super curious
can you tell me a little bit about
what social distant socially distant
ibiza parties look like
yeah that was interesting so that was
last weekend i went out with my buddy
um owen i i did the season in the beta i
fell in love with a girl uh when i was
like 22 classic holiday romance classic
fueled fueled by far too much alcohol
and some and some potent drugs
and um i i worked for i
dropped my life and moved out there in
between my bachelor's my master's and
um the boss that i worked for then is
now karl cox's manager
and i've kept in touch with him for
years and years and years amazing guy
called owen
irish guy um and i was i went out and i
met him and he told me everything about
the island last week so
social distance party at the moment none
of the clubs are open night time clubs
the only venues that are open are
um open air so places like ocean beach
ushuaia decided they weren't going to
open at all this year
which was an interesting decision but i
think
their overheads are high the operating
costs will be high
because they're used to having these big
djs
it is not cheap to open a venue where
you've got open water
like deep enough feet to fall into and
all this sort of stuff there's going to
be security costs there's going to be
blah blah blah um but ocean beach we
were there you
are sat on a table you're not allowed to
go to other tables or mingle with other
tables although
they were fairly lacks in the vip which
was the section that we were in
um but mostly you're not supposed to
intermix um if we take that one step
further to what i think is going to
happen in the uk a
venue that's my friend knows the owner
in leeds where we operate
um they were shut down last week for
having and i quote
too many people standing up
there was too many people standing up in
that venue
um so you can imagine like i'm i'm on
this table i'm on this table you're so
over there
and i'm i'm chatting to my friends and i
think oh she's
she's quite pretty but i i'm not allowed
i'm not allowed to talk to you
what i have to do is say hey hey um do
you want to go to the smoking area
because i can't go over my line there's
a piece of paper on the floor that says
like
don't go past this line and if i do the
door staff will come over and say like
stop talking
so now there's this whole new
rhythm of how people are speaking to
other groups by having to go outside
which is i guess testament to how
adaptive
humans are yeah that you give them a
rule and immediately
there is right okay where's the hole in
there oh okay i can't speak
around yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
surprised i wouldn't
solve that with like tinder you know you
can just like see who's in there
said the radio set the radius to three
centimeters and see that's right
yeah or some other sort of
mediated uh communication um
all of these things the whole the entire
last sort of
six months has caused a lot of changes
but every one of those changes has
offered an opportunity for someone to
step in
because the supply of everything
no longer meets the demand because the
demands are completely changed
stock price of zoom also did you know
that there is a chinese company
also called zoom whose share price
has gone up by like nearly 50 percent
from people
make it wrongly buying the wrong company
that's right in part because sports are
closed you have so many people that are
now doing
you know these little investors like as
as gambling as a substitute for sports
gambling
so they're just like yeah
oh man this is there's some poetic irony
in that
i don't know um but yeah that's that's
like that's a a big part of it but it
was it was weird
um scanning your your menu
on the table because they weren't
bringing over actual actual menus all
this sort of stuff
um i don't think i don't think we're
gonna see partying be the same
certainly not in places like spain um
this year um
it may be next year we are in i don't
know what it's like in america i guess
it's federal right so it's state by
state but
um in the uk we are the only industry
the nightlife industry that hasn't got a
reopen date
which is what do you think that says
what do you think it says that the
government hasn't bothered to give
nightclubs uh a date to reopen when
we every industry has from live music
venues to
sports and recreation to big stadiums
how do you think it's viewed then have
bars opened
so bars have opened table service only
um and
how they categorize bar versus nightclub
is kind of
it's a little bit loose but no one can
do anything
that would um be analogous to the sort
of experience that you would expect
in a club yeah yeah yeah but i think
it's the stand-up problem that you're
describing like in a nightclub
like in a bar you can imagine there's
some way
that a managerial or security staff
could necessitate that people not get
shoulder to shoulder
right and like embrace and like stand up
and feel the music
that is the purpose of a nightclub is to
be close
to strangers it's sadly an industry that
was designed to transmit a virus
like it's hot it's sweaty people shout
people kiss people
mingle and use the same glasses like
you know even if they've gone through
the dishwasher like is it yeah i don't
know
yeah it's um it's a real challenge so
what's next
are you what are you gonna delve into
for your next research project have you
got any idea
yeah i have a couple of things going on
nothing nothing has
um worked out yet in terms of
ethnography
probably that's because i've got these
two little kids now and so
trying to imagine doing ethnographic
field work
in the style that i've you know been
trained to do
nobody told me this when i was like you
know 22 and like
learning my field but better get all of
your research done before
before unless i do something on like the
pta like the parent teacher association
the school or something which yeah
there's some interesting questions there
too
i mean i had a professor in grad school
craig calhoun he used to say that all of
all of social life is like high school
and so there's like
you can studies hierarchy and inequality
and boundaries
and transgressions and categories of
worth in
any kind of field so the pta is just as
politicized in that sense as a nightclub
so
you know i could go for it but um i
don't know
in in the immediate short term i'm
working with a team of graduate students
to
interview people that work at bars that
have been out of work
so um we're looking at bartenders and uh
bottle girls and how they transition
skills um
and yeah i like how how they think about
the future
right now when they're when their
industry is in such shock
there will be a lot of people from the
nightlife industry promoters djs
especially um yeah bar staff
table servers managers and assistant
managers agms gms ops managers
anyone that's listening like let me know
you know what find me at chris will x
wherever you follow me or put it in the
youtube comments or do whatever
um what's your thoughts like especially
where i have a uk audience but like 35
of people listening will be from america
as well so we'll get a good insight from
there
but like the uk
really really hasn't helped the
nightlife industry
that much and i can see this i can see
both sides
i can i'm my the house
i'm in is built because of the people
that go tonight live
but i also appreciate that there's a big
public health concern and
and i don't know it's it's an
interesting one but i i'd love to know
what people think i'd love to get a
little bit of feedback
so throw that in the comments below
actually i
i better get let you go you've got
you've got two we can't just we can't
just do this all night this isn't
this isn't like 2010.
that's right but this has been really
fun i feel like you're the um
the kind of perfect audience for for my
work
from both fashion and nightlife very
much so yeah exactly i
am i'm gonna leave it with a party you
know i told ashley before we started but
i had my
first socially distanced modeling
casting today which was hilarious
because that's
um we were told to turn up um must wear
facial covering must
do everything and i got in there to find
that the guy that was running the
casting he must
must own the company wasn't wearing a
face mask and was just like getting in
like putting the shirt making sure that
this the shirt fitted like
the there was something up with the
shoulder on one of mine so he put a
shoulder pad in to like change the shape
of it
i'm like no one no no one gives a [ __ ]
anymore do they
no one cares um but yeah um you're not
on
you're not on any social media or
anything are you no not really
i know for someone who studies and
teaches in pop culture this
seems a little incongruent but um it was
a deliberate
thing to try to protect my attention
what um
where do you want people to go the link
to your new book will be in the show
notes below anything else you want to
check out
well actually i am on linkedin so um
yeah
i guess i feel like that's the i don't
know the adult legitimate version
linkedin as mike winit past modern
wisdom guest says is
facebook for wankers as yeah okay nice
i run it as well everyone listening is
on it it's just that you act
you act differently you know yeah yeah
that's a very interesting
different kind of norms i might need to
get yeah i feel like we've got tons of
stuff that we could go through
i might need to i need to get you back
on and we can have uh we can have
another discussion and
deconstruct some other bizarre world
yeah
yeah i want to hear more about like the
fashion modeling industry now and what's
happening
uh and the future of fashion modeling
that sounds awesome i mean yeah socially
socially distance castings i'm telling
you the way forward turn up with the
moscow and he could be anybody
yeah but i think the the standard for
your personality has got to go way up
right like you got to really make it
shine behind that mask i know exactly
yeah you got to go away
gracious that's it yeah like
really like expressive hands or
something
oh what did you see those um images a
while ago where people were editing
celebrities to remove their eyebrows
no oh it's terrifying just search
celebrities with no eyebrows on google
oh wow it's so scary i'm gonna leave you
with actually because i haven't told you
this and rob
henderson the guy that told me to get in
touch with you was on the show and
dropped some amazing
knowledge bombs um tinder dating stats
for you um one in five
swipes from a woman is right so it's
like one in five is
whereas the for men it's like one in ten
left
yeah and the stats the data comes back
as the bottom twenty percent
uh sorry the bottom eighty percent of
men are competing
for the bottom twenty percent of women
and the top eighty percent of women
are competing for the top twenty percent
of men
that's how hypergamous yeah that the
tinder
dating pool is and yes
they were talking rob was looking at
some amazing dating statistics i'll try
and link you guys in
looking at some great dating statistics
from university campuses
and he found that there was a
increasing challenge for highly educated
uh women to find mates that they really
wanted to be with and the implications
pretty terrifying as girls become
richer and better educated but always
want a partner that is at least
as educated and or as rich right yeah
yeah
the challenge that you have is there's
only two things that can happen one of
them is that you stay single and the
other is that you start to date a person
that you are fundamentally unattracted
to
well what is attraction though i mean in
this case
it's it's rooted in a socially
constructed norm that men are more
powerful and have more resources than
women and so i'm totally fine with
that changing and i think the pool opens
up i think i think that's great but can
women
come women find a man attractive when
their typical signals of success and
signals of attraction
you know it's the is the dad bod sexy
again argument
yeah resource acquisition is part and
parcel supposedly
as is muscle acquisition as is straight
teeth and
good speech and tall height yeah blah
blah we could go on
actually i gotta let you go you gotta go
back to your channel i'm gonna i'm gonna
go on forever if i'm not careful um
your link link to your fantastic book
will be in the show notes below if
you've listened to this and it's
resonated with you
let me know what you think there's tons
of people that will have loads and loads
of stories
and i'll i'll pass them back onto ashley
and maybe you'll
feature in the next book or something i
don't know yeah all right great
this was a pleasure thank you
[Music]
you